it's a great saying that Wikipedia works
really well in practice just not in
theory and that is true
Wikipedia success is so singular so
spectacular that figuring out whether
it's a model for anything other than
Wikipedia is a puzzle that even the
folks behind Wikipedia have faced as
they've tried to do wiki search wiki
news and Wiktionary at different times
but the idea of having a scheme where
the day-to-day governance the day to day
edits whether done for substance to
improve the truth level of an article in
the view of the editor or done for
process oh that edit shouldn't have been
made it breaks the following rule I'm
gonna revert it to have the people doing
that be members of the public at large
is an extraordinary devolution of
responsibility out to people who are in
one way or another implicitly or
explicitly sort of taking an oath to
subscribe to the principles behind
Wikipedia of neutrality a fairness of
learning kind of the values of the
Enlightenment and cannot survive itself
over the long haul I don't know as you
get more and more importance attached to
Wikipedia more and more in places that
draw from Wikipedia as a source of data
whether it's something like the Wolfram
Alpha knowledge engine or Google to
assemble basic facts for results in a
search there may be more and more reason
for entities to want to game the results
if you can just put yourself in the
Guinness Book of World Records for
having the longest beard or something
and you don't actually have to grow
anything it's like why not I'll vote
myself rich these are problems that
Wikipedia has had to deal with so far
relatively successfully and there's a
level of humility that I think it has to
maintain in order to recognize new
problems to recognize where there might
be structural forms of bias or
discrimination going on and to be able
to endure the more targeted intentional
attempts to basically poison the well of
truth that Wikipedia at least aspires
to be what would I propose is a
longer-term way of shoring it up I think
we should solve a problem with a problem
we haven't really figured out in the
early 21st century what to do with kids
who are in school for you know hours at
a time every day sort of warehouse
didn't daycare I think it would be
wonderful to make as part of the
curriculum from say sixth grade onward
part of your task and what you'll be
graded on is to edit and make the case
for your edits to an article on a
service like Wikipedia and then we'll
have new ranks of people being
supervised by teachers who are working
on the articles and on the product and
that maybe even will apprentice to the
norms by which you have an argument over
what is true and what isn't and maybe
some of them will choose to continue on
as Wikipedians even after the assignment
is over so to me if I think of an
advanced civics class it's great to
learn that there are three branches of
government and you know X vote gets you
a veto but overrides a veto but having
the civics of a collective hallucination
like Wikipedia also be part of the
curriculum I think would be valuable
you